the Joe Rogan experience we're always
talking about how wrong they got the
future in like space 1999 I like that
show I said all the time yeah but all
those shows like even I think Blade
Runner was like now right didn't we
discuss this like last year 2019 like we
got everything wrong in terms of what
the timeline was the timeline is totally
wrong but I think that the overall the
overall direction is is right in a lot
of this stuff and we'll get there I
really do believe that if we don't end
up killing each other or have some
horrible catastrophe like asteroid hit
us we're going to end up living in space
and have that kind of Star Trek future I
mean I really think that's our destiny
as long as we don't screw it up man how
far out are we looking at Star Trek Star
Trek might take a while did we get like
warp drive and all the hundred years and
we got to find those dive Leatham
captain she's breaking up yeah like how
far do you think we are like if you had
a wide timeline of like literally being
able to go to another planet well you
know well going to Mars is something we
could do
now in a decade if we really really
really want ilan keep saying that I
think he's right I mean it's it's not a
question of technology the big missing
piece I think in an understanding about
what that would be like is is the effect
of radiation on the human body
there's engineering solutions we can
come up with for that this is for the
prolonged journey the six-month journey
once you start talking about what so so
right now like on the space station I
took a bigger radiation hit than I would
have if I stayed at home how much of a
head you know the amount of dose I took
was not that much it's like like a tenth
of a sievert or something I mean it's
like it was produced receiver a sievert
if you take one sievert then you're
increasing your chance of getting cancer
depending on your age and gender about a
couple additional percent can you
mitigate that with supplements like is
there iodine that you take or something
along those lines there's some
you know maybe antioxidants but I think
that that's that's not a panacea that's
not gonna fix this problem that could
help maybe they say take iodine tablets
right if you're exposed to radiation
isn't that like something that they
recommend yeah for like for the nuclear
reactors yeah and and all that but I
think that protects that protects
function of some one under the organs I
can't remember but it's not going to
solve that's not going to solve this
problem but you can shield yourself with
anything that has hydrogen in it it's a
pretty good shield so water is great
like when I was on the space station I
put a big water jug around my head
really just I figured couldn't hurt and
and then like liquid hydrogen or even
plastic that's made just derived from
hydrogen is pretty good shielding okay
so you could have like conceivably a
light plastic suit that you wear that
could shield you from a lot of the
radiation on the way to Mars there's
actually a company in Israel that is
teaming with NASA it's gonna fly these
like vests on to try to shield the
people you can also put it in the hull
and or you can have just a storm shelter
because there's basically once when
we're on the space station we're above
all the atmosphere but we're still below
the magnetic field of the earth so we
still get we still enjoy a lot of
protection from radiation hmm once you
go out of that and you go to the moon or
to Mars then you basically hanging it
out there you're you're not you no
longer protected by that and so you're
gonna take either GCR galactic cosmic
radiation which is just everywhere out
there sounds terrible it sounds bad
Danna
GCR galactic cosmic radiation that
sounds really bad yeah yeah those are
that those are iron so heavy ions that
there aren't that many of them but when
they hit you they can do a lot of damage
they have a lot of energy they're
accelerated to like near relativistic
speeds or like near the speed of light
and then and then there's a solar then
you got to worry about solar flares SPE
solar proton events and those don't come
those are very like unpredictable well
they're a little bit predictable with
sunspot activity but but they come every
once a while no Giants
they last a couple hours to a couple
days and they could totally fry you
they're even worse oh [ __ ] yeah
so conceivably we could send people to
Mars and halfway there they get cooked
yeah so you have a six-month window
where you have to just roll the dice
well so what you can do is you can have
a storm shelter right at where you put
like a lot of this shielding and then if
you could detect it the the SPE you the
GCR is there all the time but the solar
events you could you can detect them
coming and you have enough warning time
to get everybody into the storms how
much time you have
usually when you first start seeing some
of the proton radiation then you start
you have like an hour so you got time
going 48 minutes from now it's coming
yeah just like hunkering down there
probably grabbing all the water bottles
you can Wow and depending upon how big
the ejection is you don't know how long
it's gonna last
yeah they could be a different
magnitudes and different during could
just kill you even if you have the
shoulder the shielding I mean if it's a
really huge one and and we didn't really
have any capability of defending from it
when we did Apollo and there was a
between two Apollo missions there's one
of these big ones oh boy and we just got
lucky that it was in between so that
seems crazy what a nutty roll of the
dice yeah but again there's there's and
we keep getting smarter about it and and
and and I think you know for like right
now we can send you to Mars and bring
you back and and probabilistically
speaking you'd probably have like an
additional four five percent chance of
developing cancer over your lifetime
which is not like a death sentence you
know a little it's a little
uncomfortable yeah yeah but we're
getting better and and the thing about
it there's two things about it one would
keep getting better technologies better
shielding we can actually come up with
there's ways you can do active shielding
with magnetic you can create your own
magnetic field around the ship and and
and so it almost be like Star Trek we're
like you know force force field or
shields or whatever so we're there's a
ways that maybe we could do that there's
also the
thing that we don't know we know exactly
what radiation is out there we don't
know exactly what that radiation does to
humans the best we have to go on is like
data from some of the atomic bomb
survivors and and radiation workers that
work in like power plants and stuff to
take some dose but it's a different kind
of radiation so right now the error bars
are really big so when we say they go
five percent chance of cancer that's
taking a very conservative estimate if
we can find out what it really does the
humans may be it's a lot more benign and
maybe we could sharpen that pencil and
say yeah it's acceptable what if people
come back smarter what if it's like some
[ __ ] x-men type [ __ ] yeah maybe could
like you know I mean radiation is always
bad in real life but always good in
comic books yeah Hulk spider-man is so
many superheroes they were involved in
some sort of an accident wasn't dr.
Manhattan wasn't that a thing with him
as well I think so yeah I think so I
know one from The Watchmen I think he
became who he is because of an accident
a document I believe so yeah and I was
hoping that you know I was up I had my
kids after I did that flight Oh
so I'm hoping that they would like one
genius kids yeah how are your kids now I
got a nine-year-old boy and a
two-year-old girl notice anything
unusual about them I did notice one day
the two year old girl was concentrating
on her blocks and one of them started
floating but you know man
[Applause]